manufacturing growth was I was a very
interesting session very passionate in
fact we ran we're on overtime I think
the key topics that they were raised
we're about reaching scale manufacturing
is about scale is about regional
integration and different countries
working together in integrated policy to
make that scale happen it is about
skills development especially in the
innovation sector and and is about
creating growth in an inclusive way in
creating creating jobs out of that so
there was a very well balanced the
discussion there were policy makers and
an entrepreneurs managers and bankers so
I believe it was very very interesting
in inspiration of the schedule thank you